Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing the Frozen 2 deleted
scenes that completely changed the end of
the movie,
including a heart-breaking message from Anna
and Elsa's parents, and an awesome song for
Kristoff that we never got to see.
Frozen 2 took some dark turns; however, the
movie's original ending was going to be even
darker with the destruction of Arendelle Castle
and even the possible death of Elsa.
At the end of Frozen 2, Anna makes a momentous
decision on how to restore peace to the land:
"We have to break the dam."
"But Arendelle will be flooded."
She provokes the Earth Giants into destroying
the dam which causes a huge tidal wave that's
about to engulf Arendelle until a reanimated
Elsa arrives and creates a giant ice barrier
to stop it.
However, a deleted scene on the Blu-ray now
shows that in an earlier version of the movie,
Elsa wasn't there to stop the tsunami which
went on destroy Arendelle Castle and probably
flooded much of the kingdom.
The deleted scene takes place as Anna, Elsa
and Kristoff assess what to do in the aftermath
of the devastation caused by the flood.
"We'll rebuild the castle.
New, no secrets, no deceit, new rules even!"
This original ending would have been a little
darker as the consequences of the Arendelle's
betrayal of the Northuldra would have had
a much greater impact on the kingdom.
The Art of Frozen 2 book also gives more details
on what happened afterwards in this original
ending, explaining that the castle would have
been rebuilt in "a combination of the Northuldra
and Arendellian styles."
In this alternate ending, Anna also says she'll
do away with the old lies and secrets and
create brand new rules.
That last point is likely a reference back
to another deleted scene in which Anna and
Elsa discover a hidden room in the castle,
and inside they uncover secret books and journals
belonging to their mother.
"These next pages are in English, but also..
Northuldrian."
"Northuldrian?
But that language is forbidden.
Why would mother know it?
Or dare use it?"
It sounds like the repression of Northuldra
culture in Arendelle was even more extensive
than we saw in the film, and now as she's
aware of both this and her own mixed heritage,
it's clear that in this alternate ending Queen
Anna planned to abolish this type of discrimination.
"Our lands and people, now connected by love."
There's another part to this original ending
in which Elsa uses her magic for Anna to bring
back a memory of her parents, revealing just
how highly they thought of their younger daughter.
"I wanna show you something."
"Wow."
"Darling, I've been thinking."
"Oh!"
"It might be time to tell Anna about Elsa.
I can't bear keeping her shut out any more.
She's maturing now, she can be responsible."
"It's not Anna I'm worried about.
What if we let them get close again and the
feelings are too much for Elsa?
Joy brings her powers out as strongly as fear."
"But if anyone can find a way to help her,
it's Anna."
"You may be right about that.
There's not much that girl can't do."
"Oh, her love could hold up the world.
OK, we'll tell her when we return."
"Oh!
Thank you so much for that."
"They believed in you Anna.
And so do I."
This scene was meant to address the idea that
Anna has always felt insecure about her parents'
decision not to tell her about Elsa's powers.
And it could have been a beautiful moment
that boosted her belief in herself, setting
her up even better to become Queen of Arendelle.
On top of that, when Elsa tells Anna:
"They believed in you Anna, and so do I",
the cut scene would have mirrored perfectly
what Anna said to Elsa earlier in the film:
"I believe in you, Elsa.
More than anyone or anything."
The deleted scene may have also gone some
way to address some people's criticisms from
the first movie about Agnarr and Iduna's parenting
skills and their decision to keep the sisters
separated from each other.
Another big change to the film's finale was
that, originally, it wasn't going to include
Kristoff proposing to Anna.
Indeed, Kristoff almost had a radically different
character arc in Frozen 2, which started with
his proposal to Anna happening early in the
movie rather than at the very end.
In earlier versions of the movie, Kristoff
had an elaborate grand proposal and song planned
for Anna in the castle gardens which then
turned into a charming duet for the couple.
"So you're a lord now."
"Uh, yeah."
"And here we are."
"Is it hot out here?"
"I don't know, erm..
but I think it's romantic."
"Is it?"
"Well I thought..
kind of"
"I mean, yeah, er..
and here we are..
I'm feeling very er..
romantic..
cos it is romantic.
And I guess I..
I, I wanted to ask you..
"Ah huh."
"..something."
"Yes!
I mean er..
OK."
"Why is this so hard?"
"This is hard?
I'm sorry..
I..
I didn't mean.."
"No, no, no!"
It's not you, it's me."
"Ahhh.
Hey, what do you think the odds are he turns
out to be a deranged murderer,
and tries to kill you like the last guy she
tried to marry?"
There are lots of intriguing moments and details
in this deleted scene and song, such as the
fact that Kristoff is now a lord;
how it's Anna who ends up actually popping
the question;
and Olaf's savage joke to Elsa about whether
Kristoff will turn out like Prince Hans.
The scene is obviously a lot of fun and full
of much more spectacle than Kristoff's sweet
and simple proposal in the final film:
"Anna, you are the most extraordinary person
I've ever known.
I love you with all I am.
Will you marry me?"
"Oh.
Yes!"
But ultimately, the filmmakers have said that
they decided to take the idea of Kristoff
struggling with proposing to Anna and extend
it over the whole film instead.
Kristoff's original arc through the rest of
the movie had him keeping secrets from Anna
about how he was unhappy with his new position
in Arendellian high society.
And I'll go into more details about that in
my other Frozen 2 deleted scenes video.
Now, if Arendelle Castle was destroyed in
the original ending for Frozen 2, it indicates
that Elsa wasn't resurrected in time to save
the kingdom or, as some rumours for early
test screenings suggest, there's a version
of the ending in which Elsa never came back
to life.
In the actual movie, after Elsa unfreezes
she falls into the depths of the icy water
beneath Ahtohallan and, if you look closely,
you can see the Nokk looking on.
Concept art from The Art of Frozen 2 book
shows the water spirit lifting the unconscious
Elsa from the water in a deleted scene that
might imply that Elsa didn't make it.
And there's a moment from the secret room
deleted scene I mentioned earlier that could
support the theory that Disney were considering
killing off Elsa.
"I can find no record of a human with power
like hers but for the ancient myths with their
tragic fates."
There's also something strange about the final
epilogue scene in Arendelle.
In the scene, Anna unveils a statue in tribute
to her mother and father, but Elsa isn't there
to share the moment.
And the earlier part of the scene feels like
it was originally going to be Anna's coronation
day given the very formal green gown, cape,
and crown she's wearing.
"Presenting Her Majesty, Queen Anna of Arendelle!"
And just how dressed up Kristoff, Olaf and
Sven are.
Again, if this was originally Anna's coronation
day, then it seems a little out of character
for Elsa to miss her sister's special moment,
given how close they are.
And even if the scene was always meant to
just be a statue unveiling for their parents,
it still feels slightly amiss for Elsa not
to be there.
Still, ultimately, it seems like Elsa remaining
dead at the end of the movie would have been
an unlikely decision for Disney given just
how popular she is.
At most, they might have contemplated reviving
her in a post-credits scene or perhaps teasing
her resurrection in a third movie via an end-credits
sting or some other hint, but even that feels
too much for an animated Disney film, given
a third movie could be up to 6 years away.
More probable is that, in the original ending,
Elsa wasn't going to recover quite so quickly.
So, after the Nokk pulled an unconscious Elsa
from the water we would have been led to assume
she was dead.
This would have been followed by Arendelle
being hit by the wave destroying the castle;
then, in the aftermath, Elsa would finally
have come back to life.
This ending would have been more impactful
and darker given the destruction in Arendelle
and Elsa remaining dead for longer than she
did in the final movie.
We've also got many other deleted scenes in
Frozen 2 that would have changed other parts
of the story massively.
I'll be going into more detail about the castle's
secret room, Olaf's amazing deleted song,
and the alternate version of "Into The Unknown"
in my next video.
You can tap to watch that here as soon as
it's ready or follow the link in the video
description.
And if you'd like to see even more of the
concept art and amazing behind-the-scenes
details I discussed in this video, be sure
to take a look at the "The Art of Frozen 2"
book.
Links are also in the video description below.
So, do you like any of these alternate endings
and deleted scenes for Frozen 2?
And how do you feel about the ending that
we did get for Elsa and Anna?
Comment with your thoughts below.
If you enjoyed this, then a share and a like
are hugely appreciated.
Tap left for my full Frozen 2 playlist or
tap right for another video you're sure to
like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!